[Music]
all right
g3
that is not a move we see every day
our response of course e5 right it's
like a reverse modern okay so probably
this guy is going to play the hippo
playing the center
yeah so he's playing the hippo multiple
different setups against the hippo very
effective
um
if you remember we faced this uh setup
a while ago with reverse colors does
anybody remember what slightly weird
looking move i made with with white
in that position i'll give you a hint
the poi this move is aimed against
the bishop on g2 it's aimed at disarming
that bishop
it has a drawback but it's aimed at
disarming that bishop making it bite on
granite and that is the move pawn c6
sort of a londony type of move with the
bishop
coming into d6 defending the pawn
um
f4 is should not be dangerous here i
mean it's a move but
i think we will be able to deal with it
should g2
yeah and now we develop normally knight
f6
and what about this knight this knight's
to eventually make its way to d7 knight
f3
miss take
usually in the hippo of course the
knight gets goes to e2
what is the reason for that
yeah i mean e4 is a great move here e4
is great e4 clamps down on the light
squares
yeah 95 very dubious play
yeah now i mean we're not like winning
or anything but black is solidly better
what should we do now how should we
how should we deal with this knight
what's uh what's a nice harmonious move
that improves your position yeah queen
e7
natural play
and the knight is no squares white will
have to go either f or d4 both of which
are
quite weakening
if he plays d4 there's an instructive
moment coming up
so as a hint
i actually would go so far as to say we
might not want to add poisson either
but particularly we don't want to ampus
on here why not let's think about that
amp hassan knight takes d3
we've done the dark squared bishop a
pretty serious favor we've also done the
f3 square pretty serious favor our pawn
on e4 is really clamping down on that
square so the idea of getting rid of
this knight is good that's the correct
idea but we don't have to do it by
unposing we can do it in a much more
clinical fashion
but not by taking on e5 we certainly
don't want to give away this bishop
of course knight b to d7 the move c5 can
be tempting but remember bl white is not
obliged to take
and now bishop takes d7 gotten rid of
the knight we've kept our clamp on f3
we've kept our pawn chain and now we can
start attacking the king's side
all right frankie well
okay
well here you guys know what to do
in fact the previous game i think offers
a good example
no need to uh we can castle along first
but
but there's no need to do that we can
castle long when we feel like it
um don't be afraid to start attacking
with your king still in the center right
that's a important concept
because
again we can castle along whenever we
feel like it the king is under no
imminent threat let's go let's go h5
let's start attacking and let's try to
go for a quick checkmate this is a very
thematic attack
using the hook on g3
and trying to induce some sort of
weakening okay so knight c3 is really
bad
because that even blocks the c pawn and
that just i mean he's just walking right
into this attack
but um
you know i i honestly don't understand
why this there's this proliferation of
these types of openings played by
beginners
i'd
you know one of the
things i recommend most emphatically is
just not to do that
start off by playing legitimate openings
and you're going to find yourself
developing fundamentals of course
opening the h file
is a no-brainer
yeah an fth g3 may seem annoying it may
seem that this opens the rook but what
are the consequences of that move well
let's think about it first of all look
at that e3 pawn it's tremendously weak
look at the h2 pawn tremendously weak
putting it together knight e4 simple
chess and this is crushing
absolutely crushing
given a choice we'll probably go rook
takes h2 we won't even bother to take e3
so
let me go on a diatribe as he's thinking
because this position is totally lost
yeah there there it's popular nowadays i
think to play these offbeat lines or
these systems
but if you're a beginner and you're
you're looking to accelerate your
improvement this is
basically the point of this third speed
run is to like convert people into
classical openings first
and giving yourself a basis i think
amman's building fundamentals series
which i
wholeheartedly recommend in many ways
uh you know i've taken inspiration from
it
um
and i think it fills some of the
you know flaws and gaps of the speed run
it's the same principle right
but if you are to play something off b
then learn it properly
h3
okay so of course i take c3
an instructive moment coming up after
queen e2 instructive moment coming up
okay
so i know a lot of you want to take the
rook on f1 that's not the most accurate
move the most accurate move is knight
takes g2 of course because this
opens up the h file and the point here
is to combine winning material with the
checkmating attack to do both at the
same time
well the hippo is not a bad opening at
the highest level if you know how to
play you know the right setup you know
how to respond to these moves
it's not bad
but
it's one of those you know things you
shouldn't do unless you're professional
ship takes h3 we could have also taken
with the rook on h3 but then knight e2
okay so here we just need one more
patient move
do not take on f1 because our rook on h8
is undefended
and what is the last ingredient of the
attack of course now we cancel with
great effect because with threatening
bishop takes f1 we're crushing
now queen g5 was also great queen g5
here is also very possible
but let's keep it flexible okay rookie
one
many many winning moves here
but uh let's be surgical here
now let's think about pathways of attack
right how are we going to check mate
white
well one way is to use the light squares
we have a light squared bishop white
doesn't so
this should immediately lead you frankie
with the 10 subs anyway damn gru queen
f2
okay um
again let's be precise bishop f3 wins
the game
but not immediately due to what little
annoying move right it's nothing major
but it prolongs the game
queen takes f3 and then we're gonna have
to win an end game up in exchange and a
pawn
so what would you guys propose to
circumvent that problem
yeah yeah just go queen g5 and bring the
queen into the attack while you're at it
and now bishop f3 is unstoppable
together with queen h5 light squares
again the light squares are what really
kill white here
okay knight e4 is desperation
i guess it prevents bishop
i guess it prevents bishop f3 but now of
course uh
okay
when you follow the the fundamentals it
is simple okay so
guess it just takes no take the rook
and we can go queen f3 but whatever
doesn't matter
queen f3 is the threat queen f3 rook h1
we need to may oh i don't want to prove
that
yeah i agree i think he's going to go
here
and then check right
yeah resigns
okay berlin game chess go up in the
mechanic so c6 you guys already know the
pr the rule here
bishop g2
uh knight f6 yeah so knight f3 is the
first mistake knight e2 is is the proper
setup and if black goes h5 here uh you
guys already know what to do which is h3
with the idea of meeting h4 with g4
but not and usually h4 is bad because it
weakens the g4 square and it creates the
possibility of g5
okay knight f3 is like bad but not
losing
and here definitely f4 is better f4 at
least keeps the bishop open
here we would have gone passanted
probably although and then maybe bishop
g4 although even here knight bd7 looks
fantastic like this structure with h5
coming this reminds me of this game of
larsen spassky which
is sort of this very famous game where
spassky just demolishes him in like 10
moves and it was exactly the structure
this h5h4 idea can be absolutely
devastating
in these positions
uh it could be can be absolutely
just destroy you know just
destructive i guess the word i'm looking
for
yeah i'm sure you guys you guys have
seen many of you have seen this game
larson spassky 1970 came from a
different opening
but similar right b3 c4 knight f3 e4 you
can see where this is going
and e3
and then f4
and then f4
so spassky goes after him boom
and then larson goes g3 another
weakening of creating a hook boom
and after h3 the very famous move that
spassky played here does anybody know
what move spassky played here i mean
this is like child's play the fact that
larson missed this is crazy
h4 and gg i mean it's so easy to
calculate this takes takes here check in
here the the cool part of the game
happens after rook g1 here spassky
played a very famous game
uh famous move the move queen h4 wins
but spassky played the brilliance rook
h1
deflection tactic
now g2
creating paving the way for this to
happen and white black not only makes a
new queen but it's actually checkmate
which is more important larson played g2
rook f1
check g takes f1 queen resigns because
after bishop f1 bishop g ford's mate
bishop e2 queen h1 is made or king c1
queen e1
i mean
one of larson's worst games ever and i i
really in this game often gets into like
the best 100 best games of all time list
i i
wholeheartedly disagree with that it's a
nice combination but
you know i i disqualified games where
one of the players played like garbage
but it's still something you guys should
look at for a model of how to play
against the structure
so similar yeah very similar h knight g4
is unnecessary here you can go h5
straight away
the d4 knight bd7
takes take this is already horrible for
white at least you should go see at
least put some pressure on this pawn the
castle right into the attack
and on h3 there's a very typical and
very powerful combination
we go h4
now this looks bad right it's like why
are we allowing g4
there are two approaches to this
position the first the clinical well the
typical is bishop c7 this is not a good
move though
the idea is to go queen e6 who can tell
me the drawback of the move bishop c7
something you you should remember
how does white prevent queen d6 yeah
bishop a3 is super annoying the queen is
no good square
so what's the combination here that i'm
talking about
okay and the yeah yeah knight takes g4
and you know um
this kind of stuff even happens in the
end there's a very nice game that i just
found
this is this is really cool
this stuff happens even in the end game
um yeah so you guys got it
you guys got it uh it's it's knight
takes g4 hgh3 bishop h1h2
and now queen h whoops sorry queen g5 is
probably also winning queen h4 is a mate
this is a mate threat
and f3 queen g3 mate
maybe marginally more resilient is f4
but now bishop to hg4 of attack
decisive attack
you're like i want evidence can you show
me how
the classics did it
this idea is even prevalent in the end
game sometimes
something
to remember
here is a cool game
from a long time ago
okay so simagen against yakubovich
simagen was a grandmaster he was one of
the strongest players in the so in the
soviet union in like first half of the
uh
20th century not a name that you know
most of you guys probably have heard of
born 1919 died 1968 died pretty young
uh but he had an illustrious career and
he was like a mainstay
in soviet chess and look at the position
he has here he's got that pawn on d6
black is totally paralyzed and even
though the queens are off the board
guess what semagon does in this position
without even calculating yeah at 17
years old you know he finds this idea in
1936 very impressive
well not knight g5 immediately we need
to set it up h5 g5 knight takes g5 now
why does this work
well after h7 king g7 you don't have a
queen to put on h6 but you do do have a
piece that you can maneuver
beautiful beautiful move he plays in
this position just a lovely looking move
think about mating constructions 93
bingo threatening knight f5 check and
rook h6 me
black can try to prevent it with knight
e4
but then of course you play c3 chasing
the knight
black tried rookie 8 creating luft now
somagan activates his rook the point is
that black is just totally paralyzed
knight f5
rook h6
bishop g8 probably unnecessary but
winning
rook g6 and that's it the game is over
and white's going to play like bishop
takes e6 and black laundry's the rook
but it's over it's just total domination
we've got a bishop on h8
just crushing
so
just file this away into your mental
directory of ideas
just something to something to consider
doesn't always work there are situations
where it doesn't work
where this knight g4 stuff doesn't work
but here it does and knight c3 is
decisive i mean h4 we don't have to
analyze any further and white's just
floundering on the queen side and we're
just destroying on the king's side
so this was a simple game conceptually
speaking not much happened i mean after
this not much happens i hope you guys
enjoyed the speed run
thanks again for the tremendous support
by everybody
[Music]